fin des poursuites également dans la
sphère des deux radios riposte monsieur
françois mitterrand dont un message
avait été diffusée bien avant les
élections par cette radio socialistes
avaient été inculpées ces deux dossiers
sont aujourd'hui fermé le dossier des
radios libres en revanche est loin
d'être clos à deux reprises cette
semaine le sénat a pris des positions
qui vont à l'encontre des souhaits du
gouvernement
d'abord les sénateurs se sont déclarés
favorables à des radios municipal
ensuite ils ont admis le principe de la
publicité
il faut d'ailleurs dire qu'elle
certaines radios libres n'avait pas
attendu le feu vert des sénateurs pour
faire de la pub sur leurs antennes
planche à voile venant directement de
versailles sport et si vous voulez
l'adresse se lève à 6 personnes et
sports 30 saint cloud c'est par l'une de
ces annonces publicitaires pour les
commerçants locaux que rfm bien entrée
dans le monde de la radio commerciale
pour la plus importante radio libre elle
revendique deux millions d'auditeurs
le recours à la publicité par est en
effet indispensable accès à la publicité
qu'elle pourrait être le moyen
d'existence de telle radio ce ne
pourrait être que le financement
politique ou le financement de diverses
associations dont les buts ne sont pas
toujours clairement définis et je crois
que s'ils n'y avaient pas accès à la
publicité pour une radio comme rfm et
bien je crois que ce serait ni plus ni
moins que la mort de ce type de station
pas plus de cinq minutes de publicité
par heure pour un tarif de 1100 la
minute
tel est le choix de cette radio pour
rémunérer la vingtaine de personnes qui
assurent son fonctionnement 24 heures
sur 24